[Musique]
bienvenue à tous ravi de vous retrouver
pour ce nouveau numéro de Paris sa-clé
TV nous sommes à l'université de
Versailles 51 en Yveline c'est ici que
c'est tenu l'un des temps forts du mois
de l'entrepreneuriat du Campus Paris
saclé la journée Entrepreneuriat
étudiant c'était la 6e édition nous
avons rencontré son organisateur Pascal
Corbel il nous en dit plus dans un
instant votre territoire se transforme
avec la finalisation de la première
tranche des travaux du quartier de
l'École polytechnique à la clé 4 km de
boulevard où les espaces verts
s'épanouissent la question du transport
justement le métro du plateau Paris
saacé est en devenir quel sera l'impact
économique de la ligne 18 du Grand Paris
Express quelles seront les retombées
pour vous qui vivez qui travaillez ou
qui étudiaz ici réponse avec Jean-Claude
praget directeur des études économiques
de la Société du Grand Paris voilà qui
nous prouve une nouvelle fois que Paris
sa clé est un laboratoire de la ville
durable le PA Paris saacé a participé à
la conférence teekinov pour aller à la
rencontre de ces entreprises innovantes
comme urbasens cette start-up accompagne
ce développement durable nous verrons
comment dans un instant enfin notre
agenda je vous préviens il est danse et
il sera à la fin de cette
émission on commence donc avec l'un des
temps fort du mois de l'entrepreneuriat
du Campus Paris saacé la journée
Entrepreneuriat étudiant c'était la 6e
édition elle a eu lieu ici à
l'université de Versailles Saint-Quentin
en Yveline le principe reste le même
mettre en relation les les étudiants
avec les entrepreneurs retour sur cet
événement avec son organisateur Pascal
[Musique]
Corbel c'est la 6e édition de la Journée
Entrepreneuriat étudiant qui se déroule
cette année à l'université de Versailles
SA1 en Yveline le public concerné par
cette manifestation c'est l'ensemble des
étudiants qui ont un projet
entrepreneurial qui soit en début de
projet ou qu'ils se soi déjà la création
de de
l'entreprise le but c'est qu'ils
puissent donner de la visibilité à leur
projet et avoir le point de vue de
personnes aussi diverses que
effectivement d'autres entrepreneurs des
structures d'aide à la création
d'entreprises des spécialistes des
experts et tout simplement aussi leurs
collègues
étudiants matati fabrique des
pâtisseries industrielles sans allergèes
pour les enfants ce sont des pâtisseries
qui excluent SEP allergènes les œufs le
lait le gluten les arachides les fruits
à coque le maïs et le soja et
aujourd'hui en France il y a de plus en
plus d'allergies alimentaires chez les
enfants donc c'est vraiment ce qu'on
veut combattre et on veut que les
enfants allergiques et leurs produits
gourmands les avantages de cette journée
sont multiples donc on va tout au long
du salon rencontrer différents
entrepreneurs mais aussi des
professionnels suite à ce salon on va
également réaliser un Peach donc ceci
nous permettra d'avoir tout d'abord
d'exposer l'idée et le projet et d'être
au contact encore une fois et d'avoir
des avis de nombreux entrepreneurs
ensuite on peut également profiter du
retour de nombreuses personnes en
faisant goûter les produits et donc on
prendra toutes les critiques à la fois
positives et négatives qui nous
permettront de faire avancer notre
prototype le fait d'être accompagné par
la grrou Paritech m'a énormément aidé
m'aide encore et m'a permis de
rencontrer fan ce qui me fait vraiment
bien avancer dans le projet en plus l'
GRR pariteek m'a fait confiance en me
subventionnant j'ai fini première du
concours qu'ils ont organisé donc ça
aussi c'était un beau soutien financier
et ça m'a bien
aidé on sent que cette génération de de
jeunes à la fibre entrepreneuriale
peut-être plus que les générations
précédentes et c'est vrai que d'une
année sur l'autre nous avons toujours
plus de projets en tout cas on a tout
mis en œuvre pour essayer de favoriser
cet élan
entrepreneurial
revenons maintenant sur les travaux du
quartier de l'École polytechnique des
travaux complexes avec à la clé 4 km de
boulevard et bien bonne nouvelle sachez
que la première tranche de ce chantier
colossal est terminée vous allez pouvoir
bientôt les emprunter tout de suite le
point en
[Musique]
image
le PA Paris saacé on est sur le point de
finaliser la première tranche de travaux
du quartier de l'École polytechnique il
s'agissait d'une première grosse tranche
puisque près de 4 km de boulevard ont
été réalisés ces boulevards sont à la
fois des réseaux enterrés tels que des
réseaux d'assainissement des réseaux
d'eau potable et d'électricité mais
aussi des aménagements qualitatifs
ù des réseaux d'éclairage public des
voix cycles et d'importants espac vert
ont été réalisés avec près de 1500
arbres
plantés ça a été une première tranche de
travaux particulièrement complexe
puisque nous avons dû faire face à
d'importants travaux de dévoiement
concessionnaire à la coactivité avec
d'importants travaux de bâtiment et au
maintien de la circulation publique qui
nous a imposé de Phaser notre
chantier on vise une ouverture des
boulevards pour
mi-mars coordonné avec l'arrivée des
premiers salariés EDF et la mise en
service de la plateforme
[Musique]
TCSP autre chantier important celui de
la ligne 18 du Grand Paris Express ce
métro automatique très performant sera
opérationnel dès 2024 cette ligne 18 va
révolutionner votre quotidien oui mais
comment et pour quelles retombées
économiques élément de réponse avec
Jean-Claude Prager c'est le directeur
des études économiques de la Société du
Grand
[Musique]
Paris sac c'est une formidable chance
pour la France et c'est la raison pour
laquelle il faut réussir absolument
cette opération et pour cela la ligne 18
et sa réalisation la plus rapide sont
indispensables il y a déjà beaucoup
d'entreprises et de centres de recherche
sur le plateau et et vraiment les
conditions de transport ne sont pas très
bonnes ce que la ligne 18 va apporter
c'est une meilleure circulation à
l'intérieur du plateau et surtout
un meilleure connexion entre le plateau
et le reste de la région et en
particulier les autres grands centres de
recherche et les
[Musique]
aéroports nous lançons l'enquête
publique sur le plateau de saccly dès le
mois qui vient et à la suite de cette
enquête bien évidemment un rapport sera
établi par la commission d'enquête et
l'ensemble du dossier sera transféré de
telle sorte que le gouvernement puisse
prendre le plus vite possible sa
décision après l'avis du Conseil d'État
ensuite les travaux vont démarrer
d'ailleurs on commence déjà à faire les
premiers travaux préparatoires et nous
espérons pouvoir mettre en service la
ligne de sa clai en
2023-224 cette lgne 18 c'est une
condition de la de la réussite de sa clé
être un laboratoire d'innovation pour la
ville durable c'est le défi relevé par
Paris sa clé cette démarche s'inscrit
dans la durée et demande d'être au plus
près de l'innovation voilà pourquoi le
PA Paris sa clé a part participer au
teekinof ce grand rendez-vous de
l'innovation objectif rencontrer et
démarcher des entreprises innovantes
comme urbassens voyez ce
[Musique]
reportage nous sommes aujourd'hui à
teekinov la la convention d'affaires
organisée par la Chambre de commerce de
lessonne dédié à l'innovation c'est la
3oè année que l'établissement public
d'aménagement de Paris- saint-clleay
participe notre présence à cet événement
est naturel puisque naturellement nous
souhaitons attirer intéresser à Paris
saclet toutes les entreprises innovantes
et nous souhaitons également collaborer
avec elle pour construire la ville
durable
urbacen c'est une tout jeune start-up
crée l'anné dernière qui a vocation à
augmenter la valeur qu'elle soit
économique sociale ou environnementale
la valeur des espaces publics paysagers
ou des espaces naturels à des fins de
tout simplement réduire les coûts de
gestion associés à ces espaces ou
augmenter les utilisations possibles
qu'on peut faire dans ces mêmes
espaces la création de la ville
s'accompagne de beaucoup d'espace de
paysage de beaucoup d'espaces verts
notre métier aujourd'hui c'est
d'accompagner la mise en place de ces
espaces verts et de fiabiliser le fait
que les végétaux vont bien pousser
correctement les premières années qui
sont les plus critiques notamment si on
parle des jeunes arbres les trois
premières années sont particulièrement
importantes pour la vie à long terme de
ces arbres et tout notre travail
aujourd'hui c'est d'accompagner
l'arrosage les soins qu'on a on apporte
assees arbres pour assurer la croissance
de ses végétaux le territoire Paris sa
clé pour une jeune start-up comme nous
c'est à la fois une opportunité de faire
des affaires à court terme ce qui est
particulièrement important dans cette
phase de décollage et c'est aussi
l'opportunité de trouver des occasions
de faire les choses différemment trouver
des interstices d'innovation pour
déployer des nouvelles solutions et se
laisser le temps d'essayer des solutions
nouvelles ça ça me paraît
particulièrement important sur sa
clé une ville durable c'est une ville
qui répond à l'ensemble des besoins de
ces habitants de ces usagers mais c'est
aussi une ville où l'on consomme le
moins possible de ressources et où le
moins possible on dépend des ressources
des autres ensuite nous travaillons à
mettre en valeur les énergies les
potentiels locaux notamment les énergies
renouvelables locales comme la
géothermie et enfin nous travaillons à
réaliser ce qu'on appelle le métabolisme
urbain c'est-à-dire à faire en sorte que
les déchets des uns deviennent les
ressources des autres ça concerne plein
de domaines ça concerne la gestion des
déchets le recyclage ça concerne aussi
le développement de de réseaux
intelligents type smart grid énergétique
pour véritablement mettre en
complémentarité les besoins de
l'ensemble des usagers de la
ville la ville sera durable si elle
soutient ce type d'initiative elle fait
pas tout mais elle permet
[Musique]
tout avant de nous quitter un coup d'œil
sur notre agenda tous les événements à
ne surtout pas rater dans les semaines
qui vienne du 15 au 18 mars déjà
l'établissement public d'aménagement
Paris saclé sera au MIPIM le Salon
international de l'immobilier à Cann et
pour la première fois l'ensemble des
acteurs franciliens exposeront ensemble
au sein d'un seul et même pavillon Grand
Paris la ligne 18 du métro du Grand
Paris Express on vous en parlait il y a
quelques minutes seulement l'enquête
publique sur le projet se tient du 21
mars au 26 avril 2016 le dossier
d'enquête est disponible en ligne sur le
site enquête publique lig 18.fr des
permanences sont assurées par les
membres de la commission d'enquête dans
les 14 mairies du tracé de Massie à
Versailles quatre réunions publiques se
tiendront vous voyezci les dates et les
horaires et le public pourra également
déposer des avis sur une rubrique dédiée
sur le site
epaps.fr un mot du prochain comité de
suivi de chantier pour le quartier de
Moulon il se déroulera le 31 mars à
17h30 au plateau des projets au 8
boulevard du Breuil à orsé mais ce n'est
pas fini les 30 et 31 mars prochain vous
avez rendez-vous à l'École polytechnique
pour Parion saclé il s'agit d'un
colloque sur l'histoire et le patrimoine
du Campus Paris saclé voilà pour cet
agenda très dense c'est la fin de cette
émission merci à vous de l'avoir suivi
pour rester informé une seule adresse
epaps.fr restez sur TVfil 78 à très
[Musique]
bientôt